for centuries
people have consumed bugs everything
from beetles
to caterpillars locusts grasshoppers
termites and dragonflies
the practice even has a name entomophagy
early hunter-gatherers probably learned
from animals that foraged for
protein-rich insects
and followed suit as we evolved and bugs
became part of our dietary tradition
they fulfilled the role of both staple
food and delicacy
in ancient greece cicadas were
considered luxury snacks
and even the romans found beetle larvae
to be scrumptious
why have we lost our taste for bugs the
reason for our rejection is historical
and the story probably begins around 10
000 bc
in the fertile crescent a place in the
middle east that was a major birthplace
of agriculture
back then our once nomadic ancestors
began to settle in the crescent
and as they learned to farm crops and
domesticate animals there
attitudes changed rippling outwards
towards europe and the rest of the
western world
as farming took off people might have
spurned bugs as mere pests
that destroyed their crops populations
grew and the west became urbanized
weakening connections with our foraging
past people simply forgot their bug rich
history
today for people not accustomed to
entomophagy bugs are just an irritant
they sting and bite and infest our food
we feel an
ick factor associated with them and are
disgusted by the prospect of cooking
insects
almost 2 000 insect species are turned
into food
forming a big part of everyday diets for
two billion people around the world
countries in the tropics are the keenest
consumers because culturally it's
acceptable
species in those regions are also large
diverse
and tend to congregate in groups or
swarms that make them easy to harvest
take cambodia in southeast asia where
huge tarantulas are gathered
fried and sold in the marketplace in
southern africa
the juicy mopani worm is a dietary
staple
simmered in a spicy sauce or eaten dried
and salted
and in mexico chapolines are toasted
with garlic
lemon and salt bugs can be eaten whole
to make up a meal
or ground into flour powder and paste to
add to food
but it's not all about taste they're
also healthy
in fact scientists say entomophagy could
be a cost-effective solution
for developing countries that are food
insecure
insects can contain up to 80 protein the
body's vital building blocks
and are also high in energy rich fat
fiber
and micronutrients like vitamins and
minerals did you know that most edible
insects contain the same amount
or even more mineral iron than beef
making them a huge untapped resource
when you consider that iron deficiency
is currently the most
common nutritional problem in the world
the mealworm is another nutritious
example
the yellow beetle larvae are native to
america and easy to farm
they have a high vitamin content loads
of healthy minerals
and can contain up to 50 percent protein
almost as much as in an equivalent
amount of beef
to cook simply saute and butter and salt
or roast and drizzle with chocolate for
a crunchy snack
what you have to overcome in ick factor
you gain in nutrition
and taste indeed bugs can be delicious
mealworms taste like roasted nuts
locusts are similar to shrimp crickets
some people say
have an aroma of popcorn farming insects
for food
also has less environmental impact than
livestock farms do
because insects emit far less greenhouse
gas and use up less space
water and food socioeconomically bug
production could uplift people in
developing countries
since insect farms can be small scale
highly productive
and yet relatively inexpensive to keep
insects can also be turned into more
sustainable food for
livestock and can be reared on organic
waste
like vegetable peelings that might
otherwise just end up rotting in
landfills
feeling hungry yet faced with a plate of
fried crickets
most people today would still recoil
imagining all those
legs and feelers getting stuck between
their teeth but think of a lobster
it's pretty much just a giant insect
with legs and feelers galore
that was once regarded as an inferior
repulsive food
now lobster is a delicacy can the same
paradigm shift happen for bugs
so give it a try pop that insect into
your mouth and savor the crunch
you